hallöchen popöchen herzlich willkommen
zur christmas kraft verfolgen um 5 also
hey ich bin luca und ich bin jetzt in
christmas kraft ich bin ganz allein ist
schon etwas
wir haben heute den bau vor stark von
ich kann den namen gar nicht lesen
valentina pen doriot ich weiß nicht ob
das immer so komisch geöffnet also so
komisch fotografiert wo es jetzt schon
wieder hier
ich hab doch dreimal teams hätten diese
ist denn jetzt wieder so nachhaltig hier
na ja er hat mir ziemlich ziemlich viele
sachen geschrieben ich bauen soll und
zwar rentier schneehase rose ich weiß
nicht ganz echt nicht lesen weil ich hab
das hier so klein gerade auf meinem pc
damit ich das unter minecraft wirklich
noch auflaufen lesen kann geschenkt
schlitten ein krieg mit weihnachtsmütze
sonnig mit weihnachtsmütze und das den
bau ideen für contractor bitte sagt mein
name das ok ok ja dann habe ich gesagt
und das team dem vorschlag ist von happy
trigger vn was hältst du von 21 12 12
ich weiß über das thema habe ich schon
zweimal glaublich gequatscht aber es
passt jetzt einfach weil es jetzt noch
genau 16 tage sind also jetzt wenn ihr
das video am fünften sieg kann auch sein
dass ihr später sehen welches jetzt am 5
doch genau 16 tage bis angeblich die
welt untergehen soll auf dem kalender
der maya und zwar erkläre ich euch das
mal ganz kurz während ich mir ein
bisschen er hat mir sechs sachen
geschrieben als diese andere person die
valentina valentina ich bin jetzt single
den spaß die hat mir sechs sachen
geschrieben die bauen soll und ich denke
ich brauche einfach ein geschenk weil
ich das ganz gut kann bzw
ich kann gar nichts in minecraft das ist
einfach so da braucht er doch gar nicht
an
ja gar nicht so schlecht aus was da als
baus dass er als nur gelogen ich kann
nicht bauen ganz einfach dass das soll
ein plätzchen seiner lodert wird geht
nicht und der hier da mir eine
geschrieben wird er 70 der mittelfinger
ist ja auch so
übrigens ist mir aufgefallen der daumen
ist eigentlich für anderen seite das
heißt das müsste eigentlich so seien
jetzt jedoch eher aus wie ein daumen
naja sieht man noch kaka aus also ich
habe mir gedacht ich sport loch
emotionen bei euch jedes geschenk also
für alle die nicht wissen alle sind ja
immens viel in den film 2012 gegangen
das war ja somit der erste film der ein
explizites datum für ein weltuntergang
genannt hat also ich weiß es gibt leute
die übels oft daten nennen dafür dass
die welt untergeht zum beispiel 2000
sollte ja die welt untergehen weil die
ganzen pcs angeblich mit dieser
umstellung klarkommen werden wenn das da
die jahrhundert umstellung ist sage ich
nur jahrtausend umstellung er ja schon
ist allerdings nicht passiert dann gibt
es noch leute die sagen dass einfach nur
weil sie damit geld verdienen sag ich
mal kommen die ganzen pressetermine und
wollen dann müssen geld bezahlt damit
sie mit ihm reden können nachher
passiert eh wieder nix und naja
jedenfalls bei gibt's halt schon ein
paar sachen uhr bei 2012 bei dem film
was echt krass wie viele leute das
wirklich geglaubt haben sage ich mal bzw
wie viele personen in die filme in den
film rein gegangen sind weil das das war
echt immens krass und dazu kann ich
einfach nur sagen ich halte nichts vom
weltuntergang und die welt kann auch
nicht untergehen also die welt es geht
einfach nicht also wir müssen das so
vorstellen die maya die haben kalender
so wir haben natürlich auch kalender
werden ja nur vier punkte plan und bei
uns ist natürlich auch irgendwann der
kalender vorbei manchmal sind das hier
ich habe das nicht gewollt der kalender
vorbei das ist im dezember der fall und
anfangen einfach neuen kalender und
kadima ist das so da ist der kalender
vorbei und die sagen scheiße der
kalender ist vorbei die welt geht unter
und dann glauben dass auf einmal also so
kann man das eigentlich ganz easy peasy
beschreiben was da so abgeht und zwar
meinen die auch also das ist zwar so
dass die da keinen normalen kalender
haben und der kalender von denen der
geht in die 10.000 tag und der ist heute
halt mal vorbei und als er angefangen
ist auch die welt schon war der urknall
und so aber anstatt das einfach neuen
kalender anfangen meinen sie jetzt die
welt geht unter windet passiert
kann auch sein dass ich jetzt das ganze
nicht so ganz richtig erzählt habe
allerdings sagen halt die maya dass die
welt untergeht am 21.12
jetzt einfach mal so festgelegt und ich
muss jetzt mal ganz kurz aus sehen wir
dass es für mich gerade ein bisschen
wichtiger und ein bisschen glaubwürdige
wie ich das überhaupt gestalten werde
viel machen und jedenfalls glauben dass
derzeit immens viele leute und da gibt
es nun auch schon notfallpläne von wegen
jahr wenn die welt wirklich untergeht
dann läuft alle die italienische stadt
da weil dort ist man angeblich am
einzigen ort sicher total bekloppt
theorien werden da schon aufgestellt
ob irgendwelche menschen aussortiert
werden die dann irgendwie mitkommen und
eine neue region gründen oder irgendwie
so immer auf dem planeten keine ahnung
was denn alles in die köpfe gefahren ist
von den menschen aber ich kann euch
versichern die welt wird nicht
untergehen das ist ganz einfach ganz
klipp und klar da braucht er jetzt keine
sorgen machen von wegen ja was ist denn
wenn die welt wirklich untergeht was ist
dann mit meinem youtube kanal dann hab
ich auch total keine abonnenten mehr und
weiß natürlich besitzt aber ich sag mal
so ihr braucht euch eigentlich keine
sorgen machen weil was für einen grund
gibt es nur wenn so ein komischer
kalender zu ende geht heißt es wer nicht
gleich dass die welt untergeht der
mensch kann nicht vorhersehen das ist
einfach das geht einfach nicht und
deswegen verstehe ich das auch nicht
warum das wir zu viele glauben von den
mayers nur weil das sage ich mal so
einen film gesagt bzw
dass die maya sagen dass er wirklich
dass die welt untergeht und die werden
da da wird es auch ein großes
massensterben geben aber nicht durch den
weltuntergang sondern ganz einfach weil
sich die ganzen museum bringen weil sie
halt daran glauben dass die welt
untergeht und anstatt durch den
weltuntergang zu sterben wollen sind
sich dann halt schon so vorher umbringt
sage ich mal ich hoffe mich ob das jetzt
ein bisschen gut für euch erläutert
jedenfalls halte ich von der ganzen
sache rein
gar nix weil es einfach nur total
bekloppt wird ich stelle hier mal auf
eine fackel reiner methe xbound so schön
hell warte ist es jetzt genug das nicht
aus ich halte er den mann ohne schleife
drin
ich halte davon jetzt herzlichst wenig
eigentlich sitze super league ein
bisschen größer man ich halte davon gar
nix wie ich jetzt schon mehrmals gesagt
habe dann mache ich hier noch was schild
meine runde ist ein geschenk hat kann
man sagen ja also das ist eigentlich
meine meinung zum zum festball ein
zweites ein bisschen kurz das ist was
passt also zusammen die beiden sachen
passen zusammen ein kleines geschenk
irgendwie hier wo der baum steht das ist
meine meinung ein 14 weltuntergang ich
kann euch sagen es weihnachtet sehr
schwach ich kann euch sagen dass es
nicht passieren wird bzw
wenn es passieren wird denn dann sind
wir tot er kann da bringt es auch nicht
wenn jetzt in wien seine komische stadt
gehen oder wenn man es als die köpfe
zerbrechen ganz viel angst haben wenn er
wenn es passiert dann passiert halt und
basta kann nichts dran ändern so dass es
mein wort zum sonntag heute am die
videos heute keine ahnung das entree
wochentag ist heute mittwoch richtig
wusste doch sollten wir ein bisschen
dunkel erwartet ein ganz ganz kleines
geschenk diesmal so möchte das mal so
mach das wasser zwei großes zelt wie
niedlich so scheußliches geschenkt ich
mache das ganze auch noch das so hoch
mein gott ist das ist komisch aus egal
ihr wisst dass nicht bauen kann
von daher brauchte mich als auch nicht
anzuzeigen oder so klopp es kommt hier
noch das orange rum
übrigens kann ich ja schon mal sagen
danke er an valentina ich glaube der
name war so richtig wissen was ich
zuletzt eben ran er wollte so gerne das
zu ändern
valentina pendolino also danke an dich
für den super bowl vorschlag
beziehungsweise eine super bau
vorschläge kannst der normale
reinschreiben vielleicht werde ich das
demnächst nochmal bauen was du mir
gesagt hast wenn du hast ein paar mehr
sachen genannt also danke auf jeden fall
dafür
hier stellt eine fackel rein den schnee
kann ich weg tun die verbrauch und auch
danke an happy träger vn für den
themenvorschlag haben jetzt die ganze
gequatsche war ist cool also cooles
thema finde ich kann ich es gar nicht
sehr sehr oft drüber quatschen
allerdings irgendwann nervt das thema
dann doch schon ein bisschen naja
jedenfalls würde ich dann einfach sagen
wir sehen uns in der nächsten folge
daraus dass eine geschenkte erst das
zweite und die welt nimmt langsam
gestalt denn das kann man schon sagen ja
sie sind schon ein paar sachen gebaut du
da kann man schon sagen wenn ist das
jetzt einfach einmal unser staat sage
ich mal traurig fakten hin
genau hier ist unser kino hier ist unser
startpunkt immer von hier starten wir
dann ob nun jede folge denke ich mal
wenn ich nicht vergessen und ich würde
sagen schaffen wir 600 daumen hoch
letzte folge war richtig krass wir haben
es ja immer die daumen hoch geschafft
ich gesagt hab deswegen geh ich jetzt
mein stück höher schreiben wir 600
daumen hoch für dieses aus dem super
geile geschenk und dieses ost super
geldgeschenk glaube jeder wird sich
freuen wenn das ein geschenk von mir zu
weihnachten bekommen würde wie jetzt
beim nächsten mal leute kommentare könnt
ihr mir immer noch themen und
geschichten und was sie nicht sonst noch
alles so ist rein kritzeln verließ mal
rein